[Applause]
tonight
the election aftermath distraught over
losing the house conservatives expressed
their rage
all over the country here's tape of the
chaos in the streets
it didn't end there malls and shopping
centers became targets of our wrath
ugly ugly ugly but we didn't stop there
we actually hit the streets and to talk
to the traumatized
the fox news decision desk can now
project that democrats will take control
of the house of representatives for the
first time in eight years
dealing a major setback to president
trump's legislative agenda
yo bro are you
really that upset about the midterms oh
man
softball season's right around the
corner we gotta hit the batting cages
oh all right
democrats controlled the house the
reason we can make that call
analysis data plus the raw total looking
at the numbers
shallow did you hear about the midterms
oh no but i just curled 50 in a row
awesome job bro
it is a very very big deal i think of
damn people
i want to die my hair
like black or brown maybe something new
for the fall
giving fresh hope to liberals who want
to investigate possibly even impeach
we lost the house no we didn't it's
right there on miss piggy's dressing
room
you're right muppet monopoly is the best
[Laughter]
dakota so there you go
so as you can see we
didn't hit the streets in fact we didn't
hit anything
what a comparison to 2016 two years ago
when the republicans held the house
there was this
[Music]
and now on wednesday when we lose
there's this
[Music]
so true
but get this there were protests but not
from the losing side
but the actual winners making them the
world's biggest
losers at winning this protest took
place on thursday they were howling over
trump firing jeff sessions
he was attorney general for 636 days
in trump's white house that's a long
time
it's 63 and a half scaramucci's
[Applause]
so so how desperate and lonely does a
liberal have to be
to protest the firing of a right winger
i mean
they're sad that sessions is gone he's
to the right of genghis khan
he would give you the electric chair for
wearing sandals to work
i'm pretty sure he hunts vegans on a
private island
nude vegans so what
so if that's that's i don't know why i
added that
so if that's what leftists do when they
win
what would they have done if they lost
oh yeah
oh uh
i really i really feel bad for cher
she just got new tear ducts so
it really is a lesson about losing and
winning and it's lost on life's true
losers
the left they can't stand to win that
would mean they couldn't whine
here's the chairman of the democratic
party being told he's won the house
but not the senate
you give them the house and they storm
yours
you extend a hand and they give you the
finger
but for us it's just another day we
actually have lives
you know when i when i first heard that
the dems won it it hurt
i had no choice but to do this
i'm making a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
what can i say i like peanut butter and
jelly so even when we lose we know
we'll win the next time plus we see the
bright side everywhere
for example with a house turning blue
donald trump
really actually has a new friend a new
foil it's like when the jeffersons moved
next door to archie bunker
a lot of people don't remember that and
isn't it
isn't it more fun to play tennis against
another person
and not a garage door even if that
person is nancy pelosi
all right maybe not more good news three
leaders of the kavanaugh witch trials
got booted
that's a great message
the message put fairness behind
self-righteousness
suspend due process and you're out on
your cowardly ass
i hope their next job is serving beer
i love beer finally
the other silver lining the most beloved
progressive of all
lost bato
the media
the media called debato kennedy-esque
and they weren't referring to his
driving
he was a rock star without the herpes
i'm glad he lost if only to drive his
celebrity fans who never heard of him
until a few months ago
nuts see this mysterious space object
harvard researchers believe it might be
an alien spacecraft
no that's beto leaving for his home
planet
with beto when you see that kind of hype
you knew there's less there than meets
the eye
when the median celebrities join
together over a candidate you know he or
she is going to be
to the left of anyone with a pulse
or madonna compare that to
why insult madonna she's louise
compare that to trump he got the most
media attention of anyone
and it was free but mostly negative
which proves if the media tells you one
thing
you'll always do the other no one hyped
trump as the next great thing hardly the
media
turns circus promoters and wall-to-wall
clowned him
and that clown wiped the floor with
hillary's emails
so maybe there's the lesson here for
dems trump won because for all of his
faults
he was real the dems current crop of
candidates for 2020
aren't they're like pool toys worthless
just waiting to be inflated but
maybe they'll figure it out my
suggestion go for the exciting voices
of your party
[Music]
or maybe this
[Music]
or perhaps this
[Music]
hamster as vp why not we almost had tim
kaine
let's welcome tonight's guest he's so
sharp
he is so sharp he can poke holes in
water
that's tv writer and producer rob long
first time guest he's so patriotic he
once dated the statue of liberty
author of spygate the attempted sabotage
of donald j
trump former secret service agent dan
bongino
she's so bright you can see her thoughts
from space
national security analyst morgan ortegas
and unlike the democrats he could
literally flip a house
former wwe superstar massive sidekick
tyrus
all right rob give me your take on this
week on the uh
on the outcome you know the outcome was
kind of what was amazing was what
we expected uh the red states were voted
red and the
democrats turned the house but look at
clinton
bush obama and now trump they've all had
this happen this is not
everybody acts like this this big freaky
thing but it's actually the way
american politics has been for 30 years
yes exactly it's like oh this is
a historic night and then they cut to
nancy pelosi like
we've seen her already like this is
nothing's new here we're like
i've seen this movie and i kind of also
know how this movie ends yes
it kind of in tears it does it does and
nancy pelosi she's like bobby ewing
you know all of a sudden she's in the
shower it was just a dream she's back
right
oh stop it bobby ewing's from dallas i
can't make
references anymore all right listen i
watch nick at night i get it bobby was
the more attractive of the ewing
brothers right
yes the younger one who died and then
they brought it back we're getting off
track here dan welcome to the show
yeah man democrats are are they the
worst
losers and the worst winners in history
yeah it was really horrible about this
i mean listen the split decision
everything was great for like talking
heads like me
great for business it was awesome but
the reality is it was horrible for
america
because there's no clear front runner
for 2020 that emerged
so we're going to have to deal with this
nonsense and the fact that nobody kicked
the other party's ass in this thing
is the fact that now everybody on both
sides has to make the case
so for the next two years it's going to
be like no we won because we won the
senate and the governorships and then we
won
it's like you'd almost like a definitive
outcome just to shut up for a little
while
right it's great for business guys no
you're right in fact ambiguity
is awesome because we can sit here and
scream about it forever morgan what did
you make of it
i'm just really happy that florida
screwed up again yeah i mean like
where would we be if we weren't dealing
with another florida's like your crazy
cousin
that shows up at thanksgiving and
decides to ride the lawnmower into the
lake
right but it's i wrote i wrote a
three-wheeler in
i'm from florida and i rode a
three-wheeler into the lake once as a
kid so like maybe this all makes sense
yes it does it does so you understand
you're like totally you know what you
are you're the florida whisperer
i don't even know what that means but it
sounds right pirates it's only those
counties though
the rest of the state does fine what is
wrong it's just two counties
yeah tyrus thoughts um everybody got
what they wanted
yeah yeah everyone's still upset yeah
so we're just a bunch of spoiled kids
you know what did you make of the
mid-term outcome i just said that
everybody got what they wanted and they
still complained yes
yes so i can't deal with you they are
like kids who like they're like kids
that got exactly what they wanted for
christmas but in the wrong color
yeah but also notice that the the
democrats were mad
that trump seemed to be celebrating yes
they were mad that he was happy like
you're not supposed to be happy really
great you know there's a great you know
freudian analyst
dr banderson would say this is exactly
what your the problem with happiness is
you can't be happy
if someone else is happy yeah like why
can't they just all sell it it's great
mind games it's amazing like he comes
out good job guys
yeah they're like no you're supposed to
cry exactly right
he darth vaded him like luke got away
and he just walked back and he did a
history of
of how great it was compared to compared
to previous elections
which is he had he had that already
planned